as you're looking at all those stories
that have been written about NAT what
was the essence of the true story or the
truth of the story that you wanted to
get - well a lot of it was first of all
thank you all for being here it means so
much to us I appreciate it
a lot of it for me was trying to discern
nat turner the revolutionary from nat
turner the Styron's reimagined character
or caricature as I would put it
interesting thing I would talk to people
about and that Turner doing phone that
Turner there was oh man I read Styron's
book and the first thing I'd say was
like no no no no like that's that's
fiction you know and you know to give
Styron credit ii said even in the
introduction of this is a reimagining of
NAT Turner's life but unfortunately
because he chose the title that Thomas
or gray used in the confessions which
carries with it its own level of this
you know controversy people took it as
the end-all experience to all things in
that Turner and unfortunately he was so
desperately misrepresented that anytime
you hear about nat turner it's through a
context that is uh really rooted in
misinterpretation what was the story
that you thought thought was relevant to
a 21st century audience the idea of a
hero that had brown skin if i can be
just completely Frank so often we're
left out of the narrative of America
especially when it comes to resistance
and uh and really expending blood to
represent and the the liberty and ideals
that America was founded on so as a
young man growing up in Virginia 42
miles east of Southampton County where
the rebellion occurred and never hearing
about him in school and it taken me to
becoming an adult to learn about him I
felt a bit misguided I felt that like
almost I was tricked into being a
patriot you know I knew a lot of songs
about being America banned being
American but I had so few strings to
grasp upon when it came to those who had
to say in writing that narrative so when
I found that Turner before I became an
artist he was my hero
and I always look to him as the
Braveheart type figure in our community
that was forgotten that history kind of
turn
they're had away from someone I became
you know and when I started to write the
first story I felt that was that I
thought was worthy kind of the elevate
me from the roles of like [ __ ] number
one or blood number two I thought maybe
this character was someone were
supported celebrating and exploring
Penelope and Asia a lot has been written
about NAT not all of it is to be trusted
but there's a there's a record there
with your characters who are historical
characters who lived and died how much
was known about them and where did you
find yourself having to fill in the
blanks and what were the conversations
you had with Nate about what those
blanks might be Penelope I'll start with
you well you should probably found a
little more than I did it was very hard
to find anything about Elizabeth we knew
she lived and existed and was the master
of the home and that that they they her
husband was a preacher and and so you
know I knew a lot about the history of
that period and and Nate and I spoke a
lot about it and we had packets and we
learned a lot about that time and of
course about nat turner but in order to
play a character as an actor i mean
there's not going to be a lot written
about her personality and it's not like
Mary Todd Lincoln where I could read a
lot about her and find out all about her
character so really I had to draw upon
the relationships that Nate wrote in the
story and really had to create my own
sense of who she was and what she was
about and really had to go to my
director and the writer and really go
into that and and find out really what
what I was going to do to make her real
and authentic and so it was um it was
sort of a combination of a lot of things
for me obviously understanding that time
period and women you know living in that
time period and obviously being
oppressed in their own way but you know
she was a woman who took this young
slave boy under her wing
taught him to read illiterate slave was
unheard of and illegal to educate a
slave
so she was ahead of her time in many
ways but there were consequences to that
and I think she thought she was doing
something good but yet she was ignorant
in many ways because she was raised in a
very oppressive time Asia what about
Jerry um so when I well when Nate and I
first talked about cherry we were very
much on the same page and we wanted her
to be to be shown as someone who held a
lot of dignity and strength and and so
when I was started my research on her I
found in Styron's confessions he had
completely omitted that he had a wife
and and at the time when he wrote his
novel there are these ten black writers
who wrote you know searing essays about
the the great injustice he had done in
the way he had displayed in that turner
and his motivations and which sparked
all this controversy in these arguments
about whether or not this wife existed
because they because Styron had said
that there was not a shred of evidence
that he was married because you know he
was taking everything from the Thomas
are grey confessions which that end of
itself like that was very but so when I
started looking up like okay well he's
saying there's not a shred and I found
this this one book that was like there
is a shred and here it is and it was it
was an article printed in the Richmond
constitutional Whig September 17 1831
that was a part of a lengthy account of
the entire rebellion and in it there's
one line that this general wrote saying
I have in my possessions some papers
gotten off his wife by the lash so this
for me was his you know this gold it was
like a Eureka moment like here it is in
print with the year and the the name of
the newspaper and everything and and and
even more than that knowing that she
kept his things you know we have to
remember these are enslaved people the
not have any possessions so that she
would keep us things and hold them and
that he would trust her with his things
which also speaks to how they were
aligned in their views of what they
believed in and and that she could only
get it from her by the lash like she had
to be beaten in order to get it and it
just did it was exactly what we thought
she would be and so to find that piece
of evidence that so succinctly summed up
what we believed her life experience and
their relationship together would
consist of was it was it was perfect for
me and then and from there you know I
could fill in with various slave
narratives what what else that life
could be like and flush that out but
just having that one tangible piece of
evidence meant everything Henry there is
a kind of a cliched way the obvious way
in which a movie like this is scored and
you seem to work against that in terms
of what the expectation might be was
that something that you and they talked
about very early like what we're not
going to do definitely I think I mean we
had a lot of discussions about the music
before we kind of launched in and I mean
we ended up having a gospel quiet that I
mean there's that there's a lot of
different textures in there but I think
one of the things we were talking about
was in a lot of senses at the end that
tone as a hero so why why would we pull
our punches why wouldn't it be why
wouldn't there be a heroic theme and why
wouldn't it be the same Symphony
Orchestra afforded to you know a hero
and Braveheart because very often you
know I'm not saying it's always the case
but very often the feeling is if if the
if it's like an african-american movie
that you know there'll be a certain
range of textures that that's slightly
define that but I don't see that
happening to brave fight it's not like
it's only bagpipes
you know when heroic activity takes
place the full gamut of the you know
symphony orchestra is used because it's
a universal the whole point of
especially that last scene as nat turner
goes to the gallows it's to do with
transfiguration and it's to do with hope
and to do with sacrifice and all of
those things are universal and whilst
obviously we do have I mean we spend a
lot of time thinking about you know the
shamanic aspect of it so we have you
know there's some African drums African
flutes there's a whole
different range of things in there but I
treated it no differently in as much as
I had to sort of uncover the thematic
content for nowheres other characters as
well but primarily and primarily not
yeah and one of the things that we spoke
a lot about was the connection to the
spiritual realm you know and and NAT
being someone who was so close to his
faith and was literally waiting on
response from his creator who we wanted
you know and times I would tell Andrea
like in times where he's in pain we need
to imagine that if what he believes is
true and angels are real and there is a
transcendent spirituality then how do
the angels feel about and they have a
10,000 foot view how do they feel about
what is happening to a man that
ultimately will be elevated in the
spiritual realm so we were trying to
navigate between this like grounded
practical world and the spiritual world
and and and what that trans trans lated
into a lot of times was a coral base
that almost didn't sound like voices but
what you're talking about it's kind of
the fight between ugliness and beauty
the status of what's happening so for
Elliott that's a tough thing to balance
to get the ugliness of the narrative
that's unfolding but the beauty of the
people within it and the heroism of the
people who are fighting it so what were
the conversations that you had about the
way in which you wanted to shoot this
film to capture those seemingly
contradictory ideas well they were
endless because but you only had 27 days
of shooting right yeah well you know
Nate having lived with this film for
years he had every image in his head so
it was more a question of trying to
manifest you know some kind of reality
to create a world that to find the
beauty in that ugliness you know to find
the extraordinariness and the
ordinariness of a of a slave world that
really was brutal and to do that you
know we we had at the tools that we
could manipulate which was our color in
our contrast and it was to create a
world that was inescapable
you know because obviously these people
cannot escape you know under penalty of
death so you kind of don't want the
viewer to escape you want to be able to
and also the you know some people say oh
well this story is not it's not told in
an unconventional way is told you know
straightforward but the point is it's
like being down at their level you know
it's not like to embellish it like you
know a big-budget Hollywood movie with
all the tools and that you have to play
with and create this this fantasy world
because in a way you're skating that
line you don't want it to be fantasy you
want the the form to follow the content
and that content is of the earth you
know of these people what about the land
and how it affected the way in which you
shot it for me you know it was about
when I got there and I in the south I
went to school in the south so for me it
wasn't totally foreign but I always you
know I guess the feeling I get is who
built America you know that was the
thing like here I'm standing on this
pristine land of the 13 colonies and
then I look around as like Michelle
Obama says who built the White House you
know and I'm going to who built America
and then I think about in my my
aesthetics I'm saying I'm going back to
the Greeks and I'm going truth is beauty
and beauty is truth you know so you know
you can't really find the beauty unless
you know the truth and I think that this
film for me was a way of working through
to the truth of the history of America
and you know who built it well said Nate
Penelope Asia Henry Elliot thanks for
coming out